[Music]
and I'm here with my co-host hi I'm reg
- I'm a junior at the Illinois Math and
Science Academy and part of the wolf
emerging Leaders program we're here with
John Woodard who is the CEO of Wolfram
lakhtin labs and it's here to tell us
about welcome watching labs hi
so can you just tell us a little bit
about sure so we are a new subsidiary
company similar to like how what
happened the past five years we had
different blockchain related initiatives
it kind of started with Wolfram Alpha
and just a price of Bitcoin kind of
driven by demand of users out there like
you guys watching this video hopefully
we're people working during in you know
the price of Bitcoin and we got the
answers for them so from there we just
added like Warren war blockchain related
services integrated into the Wolfram
language for developers to use and we
kind of decided like maybe last year or
so maybe two years ago that we should
kind of put them together into an
organization to help build up more
services for developers so that's that's
the majority of what we do and that has
to do in practice with blockchain
integrations integrating different block
teams that are out there like Bitcoin
aetherium arc is a new one that's coming
out they're really excited about and
then others that were working on from
there we also have computational facts
akira and piero actually showed that
here at the technology conference that's
really great it's an area where we
really excel
that's what we have with WolframAlpha
that people use with Alexa and Syria and
everything so we're doing the same thing
for smart contracts that are out there
so we're really excited about that too
from there we also do asset analytics
again analytics are like really one of
our strengths that will firm and with
those blockchain integrations we can
take the data from block chains and do
analytics on them and so that's again
like it's really exciting it's one of
our strengths that will from and then
finally I think one of the things that
we're going to talk about here quite a
bit so what we're doing with education
and research one of the interesting
things about just blotting in general
and kind of the emergence of white paper
is that there are a lot there's almost
like I think Christian Pascal talks
about it as like a cooperative kind of
society that emerges around the
ecosystems of blockchain
so that requires a lot of Education and
I think research so that you can
appropriately build tools for developers
and just tools for general users as well
so that's kind of what we've been doing
that's what I talked about here at
Wolfram during my talk I think that's
what we're gonna explore so can you're
just like yeah give us an overview of
what is happening
blockchain and education well for sure
so they're really two kind of large
projects the first one is an
introductory block chain of MOOC or I
think it's like a big set massively
online course or something there's
another of okar okay so that's it's a
massive open online course or online
open course or something like that but
that's like MOOC so the idea really is
that people can work in kind of a
self-directed fashion and we plan to
have like video content computational
essays which is this cool thing that
stephen has come up with it has like
natural language code and code output to
help explain concepts so we have that as
well and it's really a cool thing
because it's like we're approaching it
from a society and makes that involved
again like I'm saying like these are
like cooperatives think about it kind of
promise social science a goal not just
so that's one big thing that we're doing
and then the other big thing that we're
doing like tentatively we're calling it
like world and blockades
there were other names that we liked but
we actually couldn't get the domain name
so that's something where we have that
but basically one of the challenges out
there there are so many blockchains and
decentralized like services that are out
there and like there's no like registry
service linked if someone comes up with
a block team they're not like I'm gonna
register it somewhere be just out there
and kind of existing on the internet and
they all have again like this idea of
performing their own ecosystem and their
own kind of cooperative of developers of
users
of companies and so they're all worthy
of that kind of exploration I think so
what we're trying to do with that sort
of research is like go through and
gather these all up and then go out and
reach out to them and get all of the
attributes about not only their
blockchain or distributed ledger so like
the folks you founded it
community members contributing but then
also attributes about the technology
itself and the the public chain or
permission chain that that that are out
there actually using it and running it
so we're trying to gather all that
information as well and I think the cool
thing is they are that like we're not
only getting kind of historical and
community information but we're also
getting like a really a Wolfram string
which is like computable data like you
guys know we love so we're also
collecting that computable data which
are actually attributes of the
blockchain in motion as the transactions
are going on so like things like the
transactions per second transactions in
number of blocks the values of different
things something like that so those are
kind of I guess at a high level the two
projects again like the blockchain MOOC
but you help me with the and then the
world of life change which is again like
collecting gotcha so I think with the
MOOC the introductory course we really
are trying to design it with the idea
really being like a college-level intro
course so it's anywhere from professors
and maybe high school teachers who are
looking at trying to introduce these
concepts into the classroom and maybe
they're thinking of like having a
flipped classroom and then they would
use then all of the content or maybe
they have like a fee
lectures that are only looking at maybe
some sections of content but not only
providing like the full MOOC and people
want to use that but then also the
materials so that people can like kind
of I guess remix it into whatever they
want to use so that they're not like
using in the things that we may
accentuate so I think again like that
audience is anywhere from those teachers
to them users to whom want to learn more
and we imagine that it's not only going
to be folks who are developing stuff for
blockchain but also because we have like
economics and society and kind of those
social elements again of like this
cooperative kind of concept um we're
looking at just you know folks who are
like general community who want to learn
more about this fascinating technology
in kind of the communities as well along
with folks who are like many college
students where they don't have it or
high school students and they can kind
of come from from from their backgrounds
so it's like folks in business school
accounting finance economics math any of
these areas social science like they'll
find things that are interesting in the
course No
so that's one of the things that's kind
of heartache that people just need to
bring effort because it is like
challenging like the material somewhat
challenging it's like thinking about
economics and really like money kind of
as a technology itself that's one of the
really fascinating things that yeah I
have certainly learned in working with
the Baathists economists I should have
credited probably first uh-huh
LeAnn uh sure who is a professor at Bard
is a master at Bard College so that's
like something that's like I've been
blown away by that like just thinking of
money as technology going from like
Mesopotamia and like the high priests of
kind of
find it well that I guess not - but
taking like tokens and using that to
represent like different physical
objects and having like to say over like
what became contracts like you know
millenia ago to like you know maybe in
the last hundred years as we've advanced
technology to paper to digital I mean
it's just kind of amazing thinking about
money as a technology itself and then
like the monetary policy around that I
think that's one of the fascinating
things that we show in the MOOC is
although central bankers may not have
taken Bitcoin seriously even like all in
a big deal the tertiary affect a Bitcoin
has been substantial because Bitcoin
kind of influenced telegram telegram has
like this kind of quiet raising of
capital where they want to have their
own cryptocurrency and a sea SEC has
just recently stopped them from doing
that and then I think it's been amazing
like in the past I guess a couple of
weeks where we've seen in at least the
United States this challenge and
Facebook with Facebook trying to come
out with and they're like what they call
cryptocurrency some people kind of in
the industry are like oh we don't know
if this is cryptocurrency but certainly
central bankers are taking Libra quite
seriously and you can kind of tie that
back to this I'd say already there have
been substantial things and again like
anyone regardless of whether they think
Bitcoin of watching and all the
decentralized technologies are serious
certainly like folks out there in high
places take like this Libra initiative
quite seriously
so you're saying up don't have you
so it's interesting I found it really
fascinating so what are your future
plans for these projects so hopefully
we'll get it out like relatively soon
and I think we'll go up and promote it
not only to educators but then also to
general users because if we think that
people will get a lot out of the course
I think it's really well designed and
again I think thinking about money as
technology is really I think with that
like we also want folks to not only use
the materials but then to take live
taking classes with the world of watch
Eames I think having it be kind of a
definitive resource for people to learn
more about both the public networks that
are out there and then also the
permission kind of options I think
that's kind of critical to that project
success and I think it would be really
useful for the general community just to
learn more because there's nothing
really out there like that well thank
you for coming out to talk with us great
thank you so much for the interview I've
really appreciated
[Music]